so because i have a few extra minutes
with you
i have a bunch of questions also because
i'm a big fan
uh i'm curious when did you feel like
you made it as an actor
that you could just act for a living and
not have to do like a side job
why was i wondering about that when i
was younger it was a glorious day when
it happened
uh i'm trying to get you a time frame it
was somewhere around the
time when i was working with monty
scorsese and did
alice doesn't live here anymore
i think it was somewhere in that area
and then i felt i'm gonna get work and i
be able to make living one of the things
that i think is very unique about
you is that you studied and i could be
wrong but i believe you studied under
lee strasberg
and stella adler um and so i'm curious
could you sort of talk about because
these are iconic towers of acting you
know of
of you know people so they're huge names
do you what can you share what it was
like working under both of them
how were they the same how are they
different
this is really a question for an
interview that you have to
we have to have that will take hours
really really really
i'll try and give you some kind of brief
summation
uh because i would be doing an injustice
if i left it just with lee strasberg and
stella adler
there was frank casaro there was
elizabeth kemp
there was the guru sandra seacat
there was michael kahn there was anthony
menino
there were a number of people that i was
so lucky to meet
when i come out when i came over the
brooklyn bridge into manhattan and i met
the greats
of the acting of the theater of the
legitimate theater
so to answer your question as it relates
only to
lee and uh and uh stella i just thought
of something
like i could answer it in this way in a
fun way
she hated lee strasberg
[Laughter]
and i think it was mutually received
mutually felt
um i think i can say that yeah
i hope people don't take issue with that
because
they were at odds with each other about
how to teach the stanislavski method
um and uh well oh i'm sorry
i left out frank cosaro who was a
major major uh teacher i worked with
he's
passed away now uh first of all
yeah believe me i i'm sure that this
talking about them could take hours and
hours
it's such a uh but i mean anyway uh
moving on to the next thing one of you
worked
jumping into lansky uh people love
telling the story about meyer lansky
luciano
um uh bugs like all these characters
they
they people love to hear stories about
these these people
what do you think it is that people
respond to that always
they want to always see stories
involving those three people
i think in a way because there was such
they were such dynamic people they made
such an impact
on america in many many ways
um but in the same
token i feel people tried to escape from
themselves
by talking about them as these iconic
figures
they were people people like you and i
and we come to the theater we the
filmmakers
playwrights etc etc
to realize ourselves to understand
ourselves better
to find our place in the world and
i don't make mob movies i try to make
movies about people who are in conflict
problem-solving people aspirations
desires energies they have to get out
express
creatively and all too often
not creatively but in bad ways and
that's what our theater is about
and that's what movie making is about
we come to the theater to realize
ourselves
so why people want to hear about these
stories
it excites them i feel in a way it
excites them
when i went to see movies as a young man
i was excited by
seeing this and that things i was afraid
of
mobsters you know tough guys
i was also frightened by people who
cried i thought something was wrong with
them
i remember this one picture i saw with
william holden in it
he was a wonderful actor you know really
good handsome guy
a movie with lee j cobb anyway to make a
long story short
he was playing this gangster
and then he had a scene on the couch
because he invaded
this person's house played by lee jacob
was a psychiatrist
and he's like analyzing him there
and all of a sudden he starts crying and
scared me
i said i was this tough guy crying like
that
gives you an indication of where i was
at at that time life
and that's why theater was so important
to me
to approach these stories these
characters these human beings
in a way that would inform me about
myself so i could grow as a human being
was it about uh lansky this project
specifically
was about the script or the story that
says i want to do this
i felt he wanted to be seen
at the end of his days as a man who did
the right thing
the stand he took against
against people that were doing evil
he did bad things
i guess you could even call them
sometimes evil things
but when he collected his men
to to uh
invade a nazi gathering in america
they were raising money to support the
nazi cause before world war ii
that was an honorable thing to do i saw
what meant something to him
i saw he was a man that had values he
knew right from wrong
even about himself and the very fact
that he was
interested in as is written in the movie
i wish i had killed them all
having witnessed the holocaust make
sense to me
i could wish the same thing
so he wanted to do the right thing
statistically speaking
if you are involved in the mafia or
criminal underground you have a short
life and
you know uh meyer lansky managed to live
till he was 82 or 81 and it was
lung cancer that actually got him uh
what do you think
and maybe you don't know but what do you
think it was that actually
got kept him alive and able to thrive
i feel he was smart enough to know how
to take care of himself
he was too valuable to kill they killed
his best friend
ben siegel he was not as valuable as
mayalansky question i definitely want to
know before
i run out of time with you does it ever
get old with people wanting to talk to
you about reservoir dogs and pulp
fiction
or do you sort of feel like these are
these are
movies that are going to stand the test
of time it's great that people
love them so much never quentin is uh
is a young man of our time for our times
um what he did with once upon a time in
america
once upon a time in hollywood for me
part of that story about sharon tate
is one of the most moving love stories
brilliant love stories i've ever seen in
my life cinema
quentin did that the same guy who did
bristol about dogs
pulp fiction um
showed a side of himself that was so
poetic
that uh yeah yeah
it'll stand the test of time i i agree
with you i think once upon a time in
hollywood
is an amazing film that even though
people love it i don't think people
uh i think as years go on people will
love it even more it
is a phenomenal film
like i say that love story he wrote
between him and sharon tate
and that event i think is incredible
no one's done something like that that
i've ever witnessed
maybe some poets have other than that i
haven't seen it
did you ever think about directing in
your life
or in or early in your career when you
worked with scorsese and saw what he did
were you like
yeah i can't do that ridley scott
offered me
uh to direct one time we had made the
duelist
his first movie and he said hi do you
want to direct
s sometime i said i said i don't know
enough to direct
he said to me don't worry about that
i'll get your cameraman
and you'll be able to do it i said thank
you but i just don't
have the knowledge to do that and um
that was a long time ago and yeah
um i wish i had had the time
to learn about being a director
um because it would have given me more
freedom
to do the things i want to do but i
didn't have that time
i was trying to stay alive in my own way
i can
i completely understand well listen
congrats on this and as i said before
man
it's a pleasure to talk with you thank
you so much for giving me your time
and i wish you nothing but the best i
enjoyed you thank you